this evening we're privileged to be
offering the absolute star lot of the
summer season in London good stuff
Clint's last Great Masterpiece lady with
a fan showing on my right painted in
1917 to 18 this superb work is a
technical tour de force and reflects all
the Mastery of Clinton is mature
at 74 million pounds thank you all for
your patience at 74 million give us one
more Jen
at 74 million pounds
otherwise the Hammer's up and I will
sell it at 74 million pounds unless
you're coming back in yes or no at 74
million pounds we have here in the sale
room I have to hammer up and you're out
thank you anyway and selling there
ladies and gentlemen the Clinton lady
with the fan at 74 million pounds
[Applause]
thank you